welcome to the season premiere of a
beginner breakdown I am your host Mike
homer and hopefully you guys have been
taking my advice and living a glorious
life in my hiatus I've been on fire all
right so here's just some of the things
I've been up to to name a few
I've been to the casino river city and I
won a bunch of money with my good friend
James and also Las Vegas took them down
turned 80 dollars into about 400 bucks
that was good that was good and I just
happen to be on the biggest new station
in town let's check it out
the Grand Master they're alerting to
in the back alright so let's see how I
taught these kids I taught them by
beating them down alright so so in the
first game here in the first game here I
have the black pieces I let them have
the black pieces here so I got the white
pieces here alright so I'm playing black
and to start out with c5 if anybody ever
plays d4 just take it how hard is it
right
so we attack his queen he retreats back
Knight f6 attacks a pawn and now it is
protected by the pawn
we got a class going on here alright so
he plays f3 to protect it not very good
so g6 Knight c3 Bishop g7 fianchetto the
bishop now f4 big decision time we know
what his threat is now when he plays f4
obviously five do we care nope and we
just put our knight calmly back on EI
tanned everything will be great this kid
I'm playing is the fourth grade champion
so you saw my video how I crushed the
third grade champion
so I decided hey you know I got some
flack about all this so easy so I say
okay I'll play the 4th grade champion
and we'll see see what we got see what
we got
alright see what he's got alright so d6
trying to untangle all my pieces so he
takes my knight
I take back play a4 very good very good
okay all right so so I want to make him
make the game not so easy for him so
obviously if he was playing smarter you
want to play Knight f3 and trying to
castle but it's a play for so you got to
punish him so Bishop a6 okay Knight f3
but he can't castle now so who cares I
can do whatever so I just activate my
real crook to b8
so now he's like okay I'll play a Willie
bad move b3
alright so very weak move look at the
diagonal I mean this is the last thing
you want happening here so how would you
like just go about punishing him for all
this any ideas all right the computer
says Queen to a5 even my us different
jane says Queen to a5 but you know I
know better
Queen to b6 cuz I know we can't resist
putting this Bishop along this diagonal
and now I can swoop in for the big check
92 you're really not supposed to capture
pin pieces but but hey you know I'm
gonna win a pawn I can't resist winning
a pawn pawn takes e5 is probably way
better but you know all I see is pawn so
take it so he takes and he gets all
excited when I touch my bishop okay he's
like yes he fell right into my trap cuz
after Bishop takes pawn takes and then I
got no place to go Queen and and life
will be okay for it oh really good for
him huh oh my god it just keeps getting
better and better
it makes this Bishop a3 move look great
but when I play my bishop I don't take
his rook I was i play Chuck now he
really can't castle and now I can just
go in and take his stuff all right so
now
he's thinking he's getting momentum
right because he's making some threats
finally so let's just make our own
threats that's how we're gonna make this
guy crumble we can't make them crumble
by playing moves like a 5 or H 5 but
night cool night moves 94 hmm we could
hope that you know after 94 you know you
know maybe something happens where we
get this cool check-in but it's like I
don't even know so we can just play a
better move we can just play Knight f5
okay good threatening of course Knight
e3 can t stop Knight e3 nope Jack take
take all right so he just took our
Knight but in the process also took the
D file he's got one rook I got two rooks
I'm taking the D file okay and I want to
play the B rook and not the after it
because I don't want to get checked okay
so so he takes takes and now I I got the
D file so he takes my pawn major blunder
so major blunder so you're probably
thinking small right now and just let's
pin it and win it but we could be
thinking big Queenie Ford check Queen up
and we could just take right take and
then that but that would be thinking way
small too because now we'd have to beat
them in an endgame but we beat them easy
anyway but but really we got a much
faster way to beat this guy okay so does
anybody have any ideas how to beat him
what is a good check that doesn't lose
any material
Queen takes e to chuck and we'll be
living large we are up top here boom
boom boom boom and we get the fork
anyway just to get it anyway
alright and then and then you know game
set match okay but but this is a three
game match I got to really show the
fourth-grade champion you know who's the
boss here and it's for the cameras too
so um so we'll see see how we do in Game
two
alright this game I have the the black
pieces alright he says he wants the
black pieces again so fine or he wants
the white pieces again so fine I'll take
the black pieces again whatever so then
I try something different
okay Queen to h5 attacking my pawn and
of course attacking the pivotal f7
square so you know you're protected you
stop it and everything's great
alright so f4 so we attack his Queen he
moves his Queen Knight up and in this
game this happens a lot in these let
next two games even though you know your
piece is attacked there's no law that
says you have to move it you cannot you
know make a threat greater or equal than
your own so he's attacking my three
point piece tonight so we're gonna
attack a nine point piece the Queen
Queen up Knight to the center of the
board
look at these Knights in the center
they're awesome this is where you want
them unprotected I'll posted all right
Knight c3 challenging my knight
obviously I have the crusher
Knight to be four attacks the Queen
Queen moves away and we get his over
pretty easy so he tries these
shenanigans with B 4 so we protected
Bishop attacks my knight I don't want to
just give them my night so I retreated
to safety Bishop d3 thinks he's really
on to something here but not really
because I have a protected
host on b4 okay so alright here I go
again I don't know my roots attack mic
just played rook b8 play Brooke be a
please play Brooke the b8 oh I don't
want you to lose your precious rook nope
we can make a threat greater or equal
then give me that Queen egg Emma told me
all right
obviously didn't watch my video don't
lose the Queen and he's in a lot of
trouble now
so Queen takes Knight takes a is I got
plenty of compensation that's like yeah
alright alright so just give me all your
stuff I'm taking it all right
I gave me that point I'm hungry
so I'll take the knight remove the
defender I'll take his other pulling and
now you're like Mike it's a trick
but don't actually it is a trick it's
not really a trick don't take the pawn
because it's defended by the bishop so
right so I won't i won't i won't do it
yet
I'll get my knight up there making some
threats now he plays Bishop to c1
attacking me so now when I take I'm
leaving myself to all these discoveries
but all his discoveries are garbage so
as long as I can calculate that wherever
it moves the knight it doesn't hurt me
go ahead and just go right into the
discovery say give me your best chance
and so he can't even figure out a
discovery so now I get the big check on
a1 he's got to put his Bishop back now
Knight takes you know attack the pin
pieces Brooksie to was probably better
but he just want to make a room for his
King so when check happens King up now
check again King here and now you'll
never find the move I play the mood of
Pilate is just d5 removed the defender
when I play g6 because I know he can't
resist taking the knight and then we got
a stomper of a move that obviously
relates the g6
you get it
Bishop h6 check you know if he blocks
with the night you know I just take it
and then take his rook and so King up
Bishop takes now he's really mad he has
all these checks I can't believe he
couldn't resist playing a check but he's
just really mad so he takes my bishop
Queen takes a whatever go get a queen I
take his now look at how many pawns I
have on the board every single one of
him so you saw it I was on camera so I
have two choices here I got a lot of
choices but I could get eight different
Queens from the tables and really
humiliate them on on well local TV turns
into national TV turns into global on
the web and just smash them with
everything that call of the camera guy
come here look at all my Queens or now
if this guy was my enemy enemy you know
you want to make your enemies mad I
might consider it because you know
there's no way I'm gonna stalemate the
guy I'm too too cool for that
but this kid is not my enemy his dad's
watching so this isn't mercy by not
getting nine Queens
it's just I'm gonna show them how how
much of an artiste I can be by just
crushing him and checkmating him with a
pawn instead of getting nine Queens all
right so check do a little box them in
now check and look at how graceful I am
boom and game over and you know so we no
need for all the theatrics with nine
Queens people just if you've got to make
go for the mate all right so this guy
he's like alright I I'll try one more
time like I'll do this all day kid okay
so this time I get the white pieces
alright and I start out with the King's
pawn the
best move and now I'm just gonna be like
I'm attacking up 786 a horrible place
for that night that's like their
couldn't even be a worse spot for him
okay so D for a tax discovered attack
against the night here and now Queen
attacks my pawn okay I probably do
something about that and he also you
know if I take help he'll uh he can take
back with the Queen and not double up
his points all right so let's just
protect the point how hard is all right
so he takes and now once again you know
my Knights attacked but you know I can
calculate and make a threat greater or
equal than his own Knight f3 Queen to f6
Knight to d5 is this a replay from
yesterday all right so so Queen to c6
and you know I probably should just take
the well like well I can't take the pawn
so my bishops under attack I sure I
guess I should take the take the pawn
with my queen but you know it life's too
fun for this okay so Bishop b5 and then
you give it all and then it's like oh
and then boom game over right and god is
queen and now he's put his King back
I'll take that
take his pawn threatening the the big
check here and so knight c6 tme so first
we get him a check
blocks it Queen takes and now obviously
you know he could try something maybe
probably Knight to g6 maybe he could try
well I don't think Knight g6 even works
but the bottom line is he he doesn't
even want to look to see see what he can
do to get out of this so he just wimple
e attacks my knight he and I get
checkmate you know I beat him so good
the last two games by the time the third
game rolls around you know
even want to try to stop checkmate you
know he just wants to get it over with
now and he can't take anymore all right
so that's how you live a glorious life
all right